sí
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta misión
de los observadores de france 24 esta
semana iremos a las comoras donde
nuestro observador se encuentra en
primera línea frente a la pandemia del
cob el 19 lo hago a líbano donde unos
refugiados sirios quedaron desamparados
después del incendio de su campamento
finalmente terminamos con la noticia
falsa de la semana
molly es una de las islas de las cámaras
que se vio gravemente afectada por una
ola del covent 19 que dejó una veintena
de muertos a mediados de enero una
situación para la cual los 50.000
habitantes de la isla no están realmente
preparados pues las olas anteriores no
habían causado un solo fallecimiento
nuestro observador es un voluntario para
varias ong en muel y convencer a la
población del peligro del virus y lograr
que las personas respeten los gestos
barrera no ha sido fácil y algunos no lo
aceptaban nos decían escuchen estamos en
el mes de diciembre tenemos tendencia a
tener fiebre cuando hay temporada de
frutas es así siempre tenemos fiebre
todo el mundo decía escuchen es una
política quieren bloquear todo quieren
meternos a la cárcel
pero actualmente a causa de la cantidad
de fallecidos que ha habido la población
es consciente de que estamos ante un
peligro y que es momento de protegerse
para evitar esta pandemia tan mental en
la isla de muel y
establecimos comités en el seno del
pueblo y la población participa en estos
comités solo para la sensibilización
instalamos puntos de desinfección antes
de entrar al pueblo o al barrio hay que
lavarse las manos
y desinfectarse antes de entrar y
también al salir es obligatorio
como él y se vio duramente afectada por
la decisión de las autoridades de
limitar la circulación entre las islas
comores es nuestro observador tiene que
la crisis sanitaria pronto dé paso a una
crisis económica
antes de kobe la isla está totalmente
aislada hay una falta de todos los
barcos que salen hacia la capital moroni
o hacia la isla de anjuan para
abastecerse están obligados a quedarse
en altamar para que el virus no circule
por las demás citas la población muele
no sólo vive de la agricultura
algunos recogen bananos carne y los
envían a gran comora actualmente como
todo está bloqueado algunas personas
viven con dificultades es tiempo para
nosotros de movilizarnos y de
sensibilizar para ponerle fin a esta
pandemia de coronavirus
a finales de diciembre de 2020 un
campamento de refugiados sirios en el
norte del líbano quedó reducido a
cenizas por un incendio criminal cerca
de 600 personas de las cuales 95
familias quedaron sin refugio sin
documentos y traumatizados amin kafka
trata de ayudarlos a recomponerse
la mayor parte de las familias sirias
fueron repartidas entre los campamentos
de la región hacemos lo posible por
acelerar los procedimientos para
ayudarles en primer lugar los
procedimientos legales
esto es necesario reeditar los
documentos relacionados con su
inscripción de el alto comisionado para
los refugiados de la onu estas personas
perdieron la mayor parte de sus
documentos de identidad en el incendio y
además de eso la crisis de ccoo y 19
demora los procesos para rehacer sus
documentos de refugiados más de un
millón de sirios están refugiados en
líbano donde regularmente son víctimas
de violencias el 21 de noviembre de 2020
algunas familias sirias fueron
expulsadas de sus casas en charré tras
el asesinato de un libanés por un sirio
es absolutamente necesario lanzar
programas de rehabilitación psicológica
dirigidos por especialistas a largo
plazo para apoyar sobre todo a las
mujeres ya los niños
hoy en día estas personas padecen un
síndrome postraumático severo a causa de
lo que vivieron durante la guerra de
siria
lo cual hay que añadirle las olas de
intimidación reciente contra los sirios
en líbano
terminamos con la noticia falsa de la
semana que pueden encontrar en nuestra
cuenta de instagram y que esta vez se
dirigió contra la nueva vicepresidente
estadounidense cámara sabes
miren muy muy bien los políticos son
pésimos directores la aguja que se dobla
se nota demasiado
la nueva vicepresidenta estadounidense
ya es objeto de las noticias falsas a
finales de diciembre un video que la
muestra haciéndose vacunar despertó
teorías de complot según algunos habría
utilizado una aguja que se dobla la
prueba para demostrar que realmente no
se habría vacunado en este vídeo todo
está hecho para sembrar la duda se ve
una reducción de la velocidad la mayor
parte del tiempo parece que no hubiera
aguja e incluso que se tuerce pero
realmente vieron alguna cosa en este
vídeo no bueno ese es exactamente el
efecto buscado por esos internautas no
se puede ver mucho simplemente porque el
vídeo es de muy mala calidad está
pixelado y eso es lo engañoso vamos
entonces a buscar una versión de este
vídeo de buena calidad para eso buscamos
vacunación kamala harris en youtube
encontramos el vídeo en los medios
estadounidenses ahora
cuando nos tomamos el tiempo de observar
con atención la imagen en efecto se ve
que había una aguja en esa jeringa pero
entonces porque la vemos doblarse en el
vídeo esta boquilla rosada es en
realidad un mecanismo de seguridad de
plástico que permite evitar que el
enfermero o el paciente se hagan daño no
es para nada una aguja que se dobla y
para resumir desconfían de los vídeos
que afirman mostrar políticos fingiendo
que se vacunan hay muchos en internet y
por lo general cuando son de mala
calidad es porque están tratando de
engañarlos
hasta que esta misión de los
observadores no olviden que pueden
enviarle una foto vídeo sospechoso a
nuestro equipo para que lo verifiquen
aquí en nuestros contactos que aparecen
en pantalla hasta pronto
[Música]